bonjour à la planète entière il cite m
dames canada en direct de montréal du
studio 93
y at il d'autres chefs à vous mentionnez
oui et 11h11 leur magic de présentation
de cette émission tous les vendredis
s'achever oui on commence à 11 ans vous
le saviez pas ça c'est ici parce qu'on
diffuse à tout le monde
ils sont ailleurs ils sont dans un autre
période de terre ayant une région où
iront ils 11h41 en ce moment et c'est ça
c'est la côte est canadienne
un train spécial pour les hommes alors
aujourd'hui on a pour avoir l'heure
juste à l'émission savoir quel est le
sujet de l'émission vous connaissez la
tradition qu'est ce qui se passe
normalement oui oui je sais pas j'ai pu
j'ai pas eu de cadeau la haute dose mais
n'a fait que gagner avec les saints
pensant bien pâle de cadeaux laissés
chez les gars que j'ai une chance de
gagner un cadeau à la star ac
alors pour le jeu de la grosse boule il
faut atteindre 10 à 3 jeux à l'émission
c'est la tradition mais c'est pas comme
ça comment ces missions l'émission
commence par la vidéo de cinq images on
la présente à l'écran tout le monde à
travers le monde joue avec nous cinq
images ou devenir le thème démission
aujourd'hui et elle la réponse vient à
la fin si vous voilà premières images
c'est à l'aréoport au canada deuxième
image
je décris là comme dans aux sports
chaque moment intense ça une série de
mon associé aujourd'hui à notre
hémisphère oui de montréal et des copies
wii points 4 anna très belle femme mais
l'inter des lanternes qui viennent de
quel pays la chine
oui peut-être une artiste aussi
systématique et qu'il a déjà là à bâle
ça c'est oui oui qui est avec nous
aujourd'hui à l'émission qui dans cette
photo était la télévision de
radio-canada pour parler du mois une
demande asiatique où la culture
asiatique patrimoine alors vous avez
deviné vous aviez la bonne réponse oui
de façon chaque année et pas deux points
comptés vous j'en suis ya pas de points
marques associées à la réussite de la
devinette
alors on va aller vers notre qu'est ce
que j'ai prévu pour vous quelque chose
d'amusant
oui pas plus que whitney on va devancer
les choses voici le jeu de la première
boule aujourd'hui ça vaut pour combien
de points vous connaissez vous avez 10
points positifs on reste 20 points mais
plus généreux vous le pensez à bon on a
juste l'éclairage je sais que vous êtes
tout seul aujourd'hui leonardo gimeno
pour faire là la technique
voilà c'est fait mais vous avez de
l'ombre un peu comme un albatros alors
aujourd'hui les missions premières
questions attendent mais la vidéo
monsieur les 10 vidéos
mais bon le samson oui je suis pas
habitué e à travailler avec vous alors
on y va avec la première vidéo seulement
on y voit la question pour tout le monde
on premières boules d'un point g ou
parce que ça dure depuis que la chaîne a
décerné au canada le statut de
destination approuvée de 20 20 10 le
nombre de visiteurs chinois au canada a
augmenté d'à quel pourcentage points de
pourcentage depuis depuis 2010 depuis
huit ans ces fuites un nom de touristes
ici chinois qu'à 30% 40% ça c'est notre
spécialiste notre spécialiste de la
section chinois
benjamines autorités g6 gkp pas juste
comme ça vous êtes un poids plume très
bien moi je dis la france pour sa 30%
vous allez en dessous du poids bah ouais
je veux pas contredire une autorité
alors faut pas soutenir trop loin de la
bonne réponse trente cinq 35 pierre
notre technicien
je sais que vous vous laissez pas
influencer par les autres qu'elle serait
25 pour ça la bonne réponse et 300%
d'augmentation a triplé le nombre de
touristes chinois ici au canada
savez-vous je n'ose pas vous poser des
questions maintenant la wii mais le
statut de destination approuvée il ya
combien de pays qui mérite ce titre j'ai
cerné par la chaîne je crois qu'il ya au
moins déjà passé son pays
mais déjà comme l'europe tout l'europe
les états unis en australie et on a
commencé par l'asie de l'est du sud donc
il y en a quand même beaucoup alors il
ya que des pays africains qui sont pas
désignés comme destination autorisé le
jour c'est un pays ça fait pas mal de
pays même en afrique je pense qu'il y en
a quelques-uns surtout en afrique parce
qu'il tente de nouer de nouvelles
relations économiques avec effraction on
ne veut pas les insultes et les pays
africains
non je fais de la politique et n'était
revoilà écoutez je vous prépare notre
invité mystère cette semaine je pense
que vous connaissez
j'aurais pas dû vous inviter à
l'émission je à leonardo vous c'est vous
le savez je les contacte et messieurs
pour faire escale mais je pars chercher
ce qu'elle lui fait c'est à la brr je
les connais pas puis jeu parfait passage
on va le montrer on va le voir on va
même l'entendre imaginé pour le prix
alors voici monsieur castro berra m'en
dit bonjour monsieur lavis bonjour alors
vous avez vraiment un petit côté
artistique je les fenêtres sont ouvertes
si elle vend qui circulent dans la
maison avec les cheveux là c'est bien
j'avais une collègue au travail qui a vu
le test scarlett qu'on a effectué avec
vous parce qu'en fait ça toujours 24
heures à l'avancé pour voir si les
couleurs sont bonnes si tout va bien
aller
et elle vous a vu elle a pensé au
professeur tournesol oui mais j'imagine
que c'est pas la première fois qu'on
vous parle parce que c'est de ça parce
que vous avez caractère artistique c'est
sûr c'est que ce pas
voilà vous avez pas de magnifiques
peintures autour de vous parce que vous
êtes un peintre illustre ce propos nous
regarder ça ça c'est vous ça vous êtes
très fort dans le quadrillé dans l'est
dans les denrées vous vous imprimez des
directions à vos peintures se vend à 2
de quelque chose que j'ai pratiqué
pendant plus de trente ans que voilà
c'est pas de ma vie c'est comme instants
90 sur même moment où c'est arrivé et
man au canada et au canada 1983
donc voilà donc ça fait plus que 35 ans
que je suis ici au canada je suis arrivé
à l'hampden en thériault et là j'ai
commencé en fait avant de venir au
canada j'ai vécu pendant un bout de
temps presque un an en italie
et voilà c'était la bac et développant
désir faction vers la peinture
voilà donc c'est quand je suis revenu
canada j'ai commencé à le pratiquer j'ai
pris des cours à l'université mécanique
qu'est ce que vous a attirée vers la
canada en fait c'était pas moi qui
décide et aux modérés au canada c'était
lundi sa mort je suis après réfugié
politique
donc il y avait une guerre entre l'iran
et l'irak
j'avais quitté l'iran pour me réfugier
de n'importe où à l'extérieur de
l'abbaye donc je suis passé par le
mental pour aller en turquie et de là
bas je me suis rendu en italie et en
italie j'ai fait indûment toubon vivent
des réfugiés mais moureaux nous demande
a été refusée parce que l'italie à
l'époque en lait signé la convention de
genève pour les réfugiés vous avez signé
avec un d'exception qu'il tourne
seulement leur et statues réfugiés à des
gens qu'il vient de
américaine au nord est de l'europe donc
des pays qui sont normalement pas besoin
de l'avoir égorgé trouvé en tout cas à
halle en italie j'étais référé par
nations unies puisque effet sur le
protection des nations unies doit aller
au canada où ils ont été présentés aux
ambassades du canada en italie à rome
et là bas interview ce dur goodyear a
été acceptée pour revenir au canada
à l'époque il omet envoyé en fait la
langue de nature you c'est pour cela je
ne savais pas qu'il ya une lande donnant
lieu au canada
donc je vais prendre ce qu'ils ont fait
l'erreur de mordant c'est pas parce que
c'est pas la première invitation
convenance ici au canada nous avons
annoncé une aujourd'hui parce que c'est
le moi c'est le mois du patrimoine
asiatique et dans le cadre de ce mois là
depuis 23 ans
vous avez lancé cette initiative cinq
ans après est arrivé à montréal en 1990
vous aviez d'autres collègues aux
penchants artistiques d'origine
asiatique
peut-être même autres et qui se sentent
un peu désoeuvrés maintenant qu'ils
étaient arrivés au canada parce que
c'était votre cas aussi vous ennuyer le
monde durant les longs hivers froids
mais c'est possible mais je vous
l'amènerai pas si c'était le cas oh oui
en tout cas c'était un mélange de
différents réseaux mais la raison
principale pour laquelle le festival
accès asie a été miné et récré c'était
pour en faire entrer des artistes qui
vient d'ailleurs ici surtout des
asiatiques et l'eau la ville de montréal
des gens glisse il ya une époque il ya
23 ans dans la moria c'était différent
vu le visage de montréal n'était pas
avec permanent donc d être allé pour que
les étrangers surtout des gens qui vient
de l'asie de l'afrique
il y avait une eau très différents des
statuts il ya un mois de connaissances
entre les blocs le voc public les queues
le société québécoise et les gens qui
vient d'ailleurs dans cette sorte de
nécessité de créer cette pro pour
approcher pour un projet déjà réussi à
l'époque là je me rappelle quand les
analystes d'un bonnet d'ailleurs tout
d'abord il avait un statut professionnel
chez eux comme moi qu'ils ont arrivés
ici il avait perdu 7 des statuts et là
surtout certains artistes et pratiquer
les arts additionnelles de l'ordre
culture se trouvait un peu difficile de
trouver un lieu de diffusion dans lequel
ils pouvaient présenter leur travail par
exemple si un joueur de sitar indien
aller à la maison de la culture du jeu
vous présenter mon travail je me demande
quel genre de musique pour y jouer ça va
des sas et d'instruments donc tous ces
questions allant cure doit de
connaissances en fait exister donc pour
combattre toute cette distance entre les
gens il est de créer un festival voilà
été éliminés et voilà c'était pratiqué
depuis 23 ans en existe professeurs donc
vous ne savez peut-être pas mais en même
temps que vous parlez on présente des
images de l'an dernier du 22e festival
c'est d'ailleurs préparé par votre
direction ça on vous a volé sa gentiment
ce que vous en faites pas et pour de la
bonne publicité et on voit donc on n'est
ni une idée ici de ce que ça veut dire
de refléter les artistes d'origine
asiatique agit vraiment une variété
incroyable
est ce que vous faites aussi du théâtre
quand je sais qu'il ya de la danse mais
ce qui a des pièces de théâtre peut-être
oui oui c'est donc ce festival
multidisciplinaire chaque année en
indifférent programmation donc ça ça
nous est arrivé plusieurs fois de
présenter des pièces de théâtre à
corriger prépare une autre
représentation car on a des prochains
mais c'est monté disciplinaire c'est à
dire hélas qu'une loi visuels danse
contemporain danse traditionnelle
présentait une vidéo projection vidéo
films cinéma même en a plus et
conférence parce que notre mandat aussi
c'est de faire connaître le hac le
culture nous avons créé plusieurs et à
une conférence par exemple l'année
dernière quand vous avez
cette remarque dans notre programmation
conférence sur l'afghanistan à distance
est un pays aussi asiatiques et kg
propre à faire ici au canada partout à
montréal
ils ont pas l'histoire comme les autres
communautés asiatiques par exemple les
chinois voulaient vietnamienne ou les
libanais devant un courte histoire pour
leur aider à communiquer à leur culture
notre histoire a organisé cette journée
d'activités on a aussi organisé une
autre exposition photographique sur
afghanistan l'artiste qui était allé là
bas sont pas de vue c'était d'eau
en fait cette exposition en ce moment
c'est à vos radio canada chez vous
jusqu'à l'eau jusqu'à mardi prochain
dans l'espace de cap et terry à devoir
radio-canada donc aussi de 18h dernier
on a représenté de la même conférence
i/o radio canada avec madame céline
galipeau qui est interviewé par
l'artiste en tout cas tout ce qu'on vous
dit qu'il nous on en est à la
programmation très bas et qui accule ou
pas sont l'expression contemporaine
des artistes asiatiques montréal et mais
aussi aux lan que l'un d'eux sur
histoire sur le culture donc idheap au
global de différents comités d'éthique
qui vit ici à montréal lorsque vous êtes
très bien connecté
céline galipeau tu entames canada a
franchement c'est quelque chose je
voulais vous demander
il ya un aspect disons il ya ni je
puisse pas s'y présenter dans le cadre
de votre festival mais bien notre
collègue les vannes servant de ce qui
est fait un article et hier sur une
pièce de théâtre où il y avait un
artiste qui a créé cette pièce qui
voulait que faire comprendre aux
canadiens les préjugés les préjugés non
non perçues par les canadiens au sujet
des personnes asiatiques et je pense que
les mots qui revenaient c'est que
souvent les canadiens audureau c'est des
gens qui sont très intelligents qui sont
très polis des belles qualités mais qui
suggère que l'on n'a pas tout à fait une
vision
tout à fait juste ce qu on appelle ça
des prix et un mot pour ça je pensais
nouveaux seins j'ai entendu ça cette
semaine les préjugés
non non et non quelque chose c'est on se
rend pas compte on a des plans relatifs
maintenant on a une opinion
on pense que c'est une opinion juste et
équitable mais ce ne l'est pas est-ce
qu'on vous sentez ça est ce que vous
voyez ça dans la population canadienne
par rapport à ces vies donc quand il ya
dans un société on en parle grandes
villes avec 30 millions 4 millions
d'habitants dont il ya des gens qui
vient partout et surtout ressemblant
dans le jeu mais ressemble dernier de 10
ans par exemple grandes banques des
immigrants qui vient d'arriver au canada
à montréal
donc personne qui peu partout dans la
ville où ces scènes nomades un petit pot
les gens commencent à questionner son
qui sait d'étrangers qui viennent ici
qu'est ce qu'il faut et surtout moi je
trouve que c'est un peu normal aussi
comme les familles arrivent ici les
parents qui sont encore plus âgées que
les jaunes donc ils ont un pot à une
mode ou vie différents horizons plus
ensemble dans leur propre communiqué à
cause de questions de langue est
question de plus d'autres éléments dont
il ya une barrière entre est empressé
ces nouveaux arrivants société donc si
ce moment qui cause des doutes et
jugement collectif voilà par exemple on
voit zen et les chinois mangent du riz
tous les jours de tous les chinois
mangent vous et tous les jours c'est des
préjugés stéréotypés deschamps oui jouit
donc voilà selon ses impôts ça mais
c'est pour ça des activités culturelles
comme que nous faisons ça en fait d'un
réseau d'être idiot en basse et jugement
nous annoncer souci vous avez jamais le
temporel on a préparé en visionnant le
mandat du festival ce mandat et part
directement de 7
mais pré jugements et et pour créer
aussi avant l'ambiance ne tolérant de
tout comprendre de les changer à travers
de cet échange qui ont se connaître une
fois on se connaître en droit qui en
avait alors très très commodes et frigos
je montre que je marche beaucoup de riz
jeu le but n'est pas trop fort moi je me
fais reprocher la maison c'est moi qui
fais la cuisine que je fais et rodrigo
dit écoutez votre adresse pour le site
web pour aller poursuivre la découverte
c'est quoi exactement
donc c'est d'autres programmations a
commencé le 1er mai ça continue jusqu'à
le 27 mai donc le a pris ce site
internet est très plus w accès asie pour
encore donc assez facile nous avons une
programmation dans deux langues anglais
français et donc on a quatre activités
par semaine
mais le sommet commence par jeudi
vendredi samedi dimanche
on a commencé notre troisième semaine le
hyères en évitant des spectacles de
danse et maisons de la culture ainsi que
ce soir de la sala rossa avec un groupe
de musique un mélange de musiciens de
différents pays asiatiques céréales et
iranienne avec un partenaire de danse
aussi en continu de m'asseoir en une
représentation de danse contemporaine
avec trois artistes d'origine asiatique
les chinois et vietnamiens dans la
maison de la culture clac montréal la
semaine prochaine nous aussi on continue
avec une élément international on a
invité un artiste de grande valeur qui
devient d'amsterdam d'origine iranienne
avec une autre artiste qui viennent et
de toronto d'humour gamme ation de danse
classique en deux iraniens deux artistes
font sur le sel gesù centre de
créativité le jeudi et voilà où si on a
volé le public extérieur donc s'appelle
voir d'asie ça commence vendredi dans
les jardins de gamme l'année où si
samedi ça continue en après midi avec
quatre roues pour la communauté
asiatique philippines
chez l'iran est libre j'ai fondé danses
de différents pays traditionnels c'est
extraordinaire ça l'extérieur donc voilà
que très bien alors triple w accès à six
points comme c'est noté merci beaucoup
professeur tournesol
monsieur acheter ramadi oui bonne
journée à m
voilà nous on n'est pas sérieux ne s'est
pas séparé du ca du canada international
avec celle du geste
écoutez vous avez le choix ici c'est
comme beaucoup de choses dans la vie
vous pouvez dicter la suite des choses
vous êtes pas comme dans bien des
milieux vous pouvez me dire je vais
avoir une mission courte une mission
plus longue que vous choisissez
maintenant c'est comme un jeu vidéo
le chemin est plus de points gagnés à la
version longue ajouté
blanc on a voté prend toujours là chemin
au milieu alors vous voulez cours mais à
peu près 45 minutes
oui c'est ça on peut pas dépasser il
faut expliquer que oui et talent pendant
une heure tout toutes leurs précédentes
pour la version de son équipe de
l'équipe chinoise et chaire du canada
lance hilare tant qu'elle est en studio
et moi je suis elle va être avec les
anglais après si c'est vrai non c'est
pas vrai c'est moi qui va être avec vous
les espagnols les anglais c'est bon
quand moi je alors écoutez on va aller
vers le deuxième la plus de vidéos
numéro 5 je pense oui de vue 2 2 le jeu
de la boule voit la deuxième manche
c'est ça on est prêt pour ça c'est très
bien parce que là ya de l'argent à
gagner
voici la question oui vous allez me dire
quelle est la deuxième question au jeu
aujourd'hui à partir à partir de quelle
année les gens se mettent dire à fuir le
viêt-nam parce que le régime communiste
du nord à renverser le gouvernement du
vietnam du sud
je peux répondre j'ai l'impression que
c'est à partir de soixante dix 1970 60
ou 70 71 faut rappeler que c'est à cette
époque là que sont arrivés les premiers
bodipo dans le monde notamment au canada
lacc au canada on a eu la première vague
d'immigration d'origine asiatique
donc il ya beaucoup de gens qui viennent
de l'asie maintenant depuis les dix ou
vingt dernières années surtout depuis
dix ans mais là les premières première
premier première génération qui est
arrivé au canada en 1967 on n'est pas
loin de la bonne réponse 70-72 faut
préciser a il faut seulement dire et à
dire un chiffre on est passé de 72 72
dans les années 70 c'est ça faut pas
tout vous trouve tout court la décennie
à vous tout seul sans laisser aux autres
je dirais que parce que la question se
pose et au début quand aussi qu'en dix
ans
pensez donc pas de grandes vagues mais
quand ils ont commencé moi je dis les
soixante dix 70 très bien ce 80 ans ce
genre de choses il ya toujours des gens
qui ont prévu ce qui va arriver que ce
qui allait arriver y par secrètement
discrètement déjà avant les autres il ya
des gens comme ça donc avant la grande
vague des bons joueurs joueuses hiromi
dieu 72 mais vous aussi non seulement
lui l'a dit 70 71
vous pouvez dire la même chose alors la
question on le rappelle c'est où est ce
qu'il est la question
je les peins je vais pas vous n'avez pas
non à partir desquels les oui et on
parlait de la chute de saïgon alors le
sud essayons ne s'est pas produite en
1972-73 114
mais en 1975 qui était le plus proche
des bonnes réponses
félicitations vous avez 30 points c'est
ça et qui avait collecté les 20 points
plus tôt elle aussi l avez vous aussi
vous gagnez il faut vous en souvenir au
la chute de 5 ans et 1 75 75
oui d'accord je vous apprends rien
j'espère mais je suis attaque elle déjà
les gens qui ont commencé en 77
discrètement absolument il savait déjà
je vais écouter quand il ya des
problèmes économiques les gens avec du
pouvoir il commence à sortir de l'argent
avant qui la débâcle y arrive la même
chose se passe quand ya des problèmes
politiques à ce niveau là les jeunes
commencent à fuir avant parce qu'ils qu
ils reconnaissent certains mouvement
social puis reconnaît sa santé
clin d'oeil de la part du politique à
l'aller commence à apprendre surtout
ceux qui sont dans le gouvernement
quitte le gouvernement
je me souviens qu'il ya un peintre il ya
une peintre en fait montréalais ce qui a
été invité plusieurs fois ici qui parle
très bien français d'ailleurs anglais je
pense que c'est ça ça ses parents l'ont
envoyé comme étudiant étrangères comme
internationaux commencent avant le but
en fait de fuir les belles histoires des
belles histoires ce sont des histoires
extrêmement touchante à raconter les
rigueurs d'auteur il a soupé bec
maintenant kim thùy kim tillie qui écrit
des romans mais saute sur des romans
mais basé sur sa vie à qu'elle était
bébé j'ai lu c'est magnifique
le premier c'est russell
le premier le plus frappant c'est
fantastique
si vous allez dans l'onglet découvrir
sur la page de radio canada
international de les voir qu'un dossier
sur l'immigration où il était question
notamment des réfugiés de la mer un
portrait de ces gens qui sont nés de
cette émigration à l'époque où qui sont
venus avec leurs parents dans ces
bateaux et qui ont gagné la côte
canadienne dans la région de vancouver
c'est là qu'on atterrisse c'est cela
qu'on arrivait je vais vous parler de
quelqu'un qui est né après on va parler
après on a parlé beaucoup avant par la
maintenant après d'accord ce léger qu'on
à faire beaucoup et très bien alors je
vais vous proposer ici une entrevue
vidéo numéro 8
je vous guide avec les chiffres c'est
plus facile oui c'est à s'y perdre
sinon alors c'est chez eux en femme
c'est un nom qui devrait vous dire
quelque chose ici à radio canada
ne vous en faites pas si c'est pas qu'un
on le découpe une entrevue de réseaux
canard est quand même présenté lé
journaliste à radio canada corp et on
lui demande est dans le camp du mois sur
des festivités autour de l'asie de faire
cinq vidéos qui viennent casser un peu
les préjugés qu'on peut avoir par
rapport aux personnes d'origine
asiatique
elle va vous donner un exemple très
précis et ensuite elle va vous parler de
son expérience personnelle
si vous la voir l'intégrale de cette
entrevue je vous le dis tout de suite je
pense déjà après moi ce sera lundi dans
le cadre de notre page web radio canada
international services français entrevue
intégral
réalisé par marie claude simard puis un
plus il ya aussi un site spécialisé des
radios nationales que c'est justement le
site des festivités 7 - si on fait un
site spécial pour les patrimoines
génétiques très bien vous allez nous y
amener dans un stand alone et stages
vous montre comment y arriver
pour le moment l'entrevue avec notre
collègue de la salle du nouvel an au
chaud en femme
c'est ce qui des allemands si on était
dans un monde parfait y en aurait pas de
mode patrimoine asiatique puis on serait
tous en symbiose en fait tout s'est
parfaitement intégré mais là comme ça -
là existe une initiative du gouvernement
du canada pour mettre en utilisant cette
opportunité la partie en cette fenêtre
là parce que simplement dans les médias
cherchent que c'est nécessairement ce
qui
fonds en actions jusqu'en nécessairement
ceux qui sont journalistes qui sont
présentateur mais si on regarde
bultel nouvelle conventionnel souvent
les personnes pour reprendre
dans le reportage pour illustrer la
hausse de l'essence pour illustrer
l'impact du nouveau budget du québec ou
du canada sur une famille type
c'est rare qu'on voit des gens issus des
communautés culturelles et le sport pas
juste pour les asiatiques mais pour les
communautés noires également pour toutes
les minorités visez donc je pense que je
me suis dit profitons de cette vitrine
là pour les mettre en valeur et faire
comprendre aux gens que
les communautés culturelles c'est juste
quelque chose d'unique et de l'existence
et pas juste quelque chose d'ethnies et
de cultures l on est on fait aussi
partie de la société c'est important
est ce que tu peux parler brièvement de
théorie j'ai ma foi oui moi je suis
d'origine vietnamienne
je suis né à montréal en fait je suis la
première de la génération dans la
famille a étonné
québec mes parents ont quitté vietnam
tout de suite après la guerre dont moi
je me vois autant québécois ce que
vietnamiens j'ai peut-être
honnêtement je suis beaucoup plus
québécoise dans dans la culture dans ce
que j dans ce que je suis je parle mieux
français qui l'animent n'empêche
ce que j'ai deux vietnamiens en moi
j'étais plus et j'y crois fortement puis
ça c'est certain
de toute ma personne ici qu'est ce que
tu sens que ton héritage vietnam y et
apporte une contribution importante dans
ton travail à l'attelé canada
je sais pas sur mon regard différent je
peux pas dire que je suis très
représentative de l'ensemble de la
communauté malienne chez une personne de
deuxième génération aussi moi c'est sûr
que ce qu'on voit souvent cédé première
génération des souffrances qui viennent
d'arriver dans soit dans des reportages
sur l'intégration sur la francisation
mais moi quand je vois cette personne là
je ne me reconnais pas la corde et c'est
important pour tenter de trouver un
espace aussi pour les deuxième troisième
génération qui veulent être vus qui
veulent être entendus
washington moi j'ai quatre enfants jean
ne fera donc
moi je suis d'origine vietnamienne mais
le papa est d'origine canadienne et j'ai
eu mes gars ont récemment les revenus de
la garderie avec un dessin de cupidon
pour la saint valentin et avait décidé
que cupidon avait la peau brune et pour
mon garçon son idole s'était piqué
souvent et c'était le personnage de film
dans star wars même qui me décider je
dis que j'aimerais savoir la même
maladie que michael jackson est allé
vers lui rêvait savoir la poudre
je me dis des choses formidables ici on
ne manque pas des gens des modèles de
des gens issus de communautés
culturelles on ne leur montent pas seul
jeudi
encore une fois une entrevue intégral
disponible seulement lundi faudra
patienter pour le moment c'était c'était
une façon de vous amener vers notre site
internet comme il se doit
et puis on va aller vers cette section
tel que promis section spéciale proposée
par radio canada international nous nous
hébergeons tous les reportages entrevue
réalisée dans le cadre de ce mois par
les différentes équipes de radio canada
radio canada international que ce soit
ici à montréal ou ailleurs au pays lance
et on s'est cru qu'on se promène pour
notre site en français un fait si vous
allez avoir ici à côté droit
en haut une hyper lien qui vous envoie
directement sur le site de patricia tic
en français en fait c'est dans cinq
langues
vous pouvez faire les parcours dans
n'importe quelle des langues de radio
canada international puis l'intégrale
des productions qui ont fait qu'ils ont
le rapport avec les communautés
asiatiques sont là voilà c'est vraiment
très intéressant vous jetez un coup
d'oeil c'est pas difficile d'y arriver
puis on a des choses qu'ils ont fait
cette année puis aussi des choses qu'ils
ont fait parce qu'on a commencé avec ces
sites là ça fait à peu près cinq ans
alors on a aussi des choses son ancien
mais qui sont et son parent est liée au
temps ça veut dire que intemporel qui on
peut vraiment faire le parcours puis en
profiter quand je sais leonardo vous
avez été occupé aujourd'hui n'ayez pas
l'occasion de vous concentrer sur les
questions du fameux jeu de la grosse
boule
c'est dommage parce que je sais que vous
avez plus que votre tête
et puis on va se tourner vers la
troisième question maintenant alors il
s'agit de la vidéo numéro 8 pour ceux
qui comptent
ok on a représenté que 4 aujourd'hui je
pense aussi à 8
l'a8 on vient de les faire c'est vrai
c'est vrai ouais bien une neuvième vidéo
à cette émission
la vidéo chanceuses ont ni on la regarde
ensemble et on va demander
oui nous lire encore une fois cette
question très court quel pourcentage de
la population de la région de vancouver
est origine asiatique à weesp aux
questions et on va pas vous demander à
vous tout de suite on va atteindre parce
que j'en pensais que vous avez toujours
les bonnes réponses aujourd'hui
leonardo 10 128 pense à 28 pour ça
d'accord parce que parce que oui très
bon raison très positif vous marque et
40 % d'accord 28 28 40
et vous oui 45 à 50 % 45 à 50 ses
proches de la moitié j'ai l'impression
c'est vrai attendez voir que je suis
j'ai la bonne réponse et origine
asiatique c'est à dire ceux qui sont ici
mais tu es avec tes parents
c'est excessif auspices il faut
spécifier alors la bonne réponse et un
tiers de la population 33% la population
alors je dis vous avez dit 45 non si je
peux jouer niveau c'est elle qui 28 28
28 mai vous avez dit 40
oui c'est dommage de pas 10 32 voskamp
alors 50 points et 50 points c'est une
compétition très divisée aujourd'hui
j'ai eu là on peut poser une quatrième
question est vraiment départir le bloc
tous les deux gagné pas demander mieux
c'est la note des shoes avaient tous les
deux échoué à 50 seulement mais c'est
quand vous avez la décourager je suis un
petit peu découragé mais c'est pas grave
écoutez l'importance est anticipée c'est
ce que je peux faire chaque semaine
écoutez merci beaucoup d'être venu speed
semaine pour cette équipe réduite de
tam-tam canada et puis
oui vous allez pouvoir enfin quitter le
studio c'est pendant 1h45 vous êtes
resté cloué comme ça c'est quelque chose
c'est spécial et merci beaucoup
ça me fait plaisir très bientôt un autre
10 points vous qui avez fait de la djia
gagné nommé you connue elle a gagné mais
vous êtes habitués écoutez un jour
faudrait que vous me retourner la boule
de lanciers et vous on devrait faire ça
m'a emmené voir jusqu'à quel point je ne
connais aucune réponse il va nous dire
des quoi on va faire la question
peut-être ça va être à lui de répondre
ce ne sera pas demain la veille à en
termes de territoire oui quelle est la
plus grande province au canada le québec
j'ai pas besoin de visiter deuxième
l'ontario où la troisième d'accord
britannique population population c'est
facile on n'a pas même pas la population
c'est l'ontario écoutez poser des
questions complexes qui vous conviennent
des tremblay a au québec c'est là
c'était la plus grosse famille je ne
sais pas si c'est encore le cas mais je
peux pas répondre à votre question
saint-venant pas un million dans les
centaines de milliers probablement
faudra vérifier c'est tout il ya une
publicité qu'il fasse une loi passée à
vous faut payer les salaires remercie
oui où
à bientôt et merci moi comme lui à
bientôt également versé beaucoup et puis
les honneurs gimeno faudra vous
débrouiller sans moi pour les quatre
prochaines semaines paquet a pas de
problème je pars en vacances
et puis je sais que vous serez de la
semaine prochaine - 12e tout va bien se
passer
merci beaucoup je vous regarderez
peut-être alors on regarde quelle caméra
pour celui la planète les deux sont là
pis là pour ça